hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my newsletter subscribers
Chris who is starting his fifth business
he's had all his other businesses fail
his wife is threatening to leave him if
this business doesn't worked out he
started a new company he's been working
80 hours per week and is shut down
because he's working too much his body's
shutting down on him and he started a
new business now he has total and
familiarity with and wanted my advice on
how to get it going to succeed so that
no saves its business ages marriage and
has a happy life this is a tough one and
I'm really sorry that's kind of gotten
at this point where it's so serious with
your wife and all these failed
businesses before the biggest thing that
is challenging for me is that you have
no familiarity with this business and
and one thing that you see from
successful entrepreneurs is the ones who
really make it are the ones who have a
strong passion fourth of doing so they
really get their business and they're
really excited about doing it and they
know everything of the experts in their
field so if you have a total unfamiliar
arity with it what I would suggest is
try to find somebody who knows that
business and partner up with them and
get somebody involved who can do the
things that you not quite sure about and
give them incentive to to do that job
well ideally would be start a business
that you are passionate about and you
have some connections with and you feel
you can add a lot of value you know to
start making money the amount of money
you're going to make is going to be in
direct proportion to how much you value
out to people so the more you help
people the more value can add the more
money you can make and that usually
comes from really knowing your industry
and something you're really excited
about so you know with this new business
think about how can you add as much
value to potential customers as possible
and what might help is is building
around the customer so I don't know what
the new business is but try to find a
customer ideally a business customer who
could be a repeat order for you
and try to make yourself an
indispensable part of your business you
know if you're working with a company
and they see you as being indispensable
you're adding so much value to them
you're helping them out so much they're
going to keep wanting to work more with
you tell their colleagues about you you
know increase the contract size give you
more work so it's a great potential
opportunity if you can sell to a
business and build around their needs
instead of just launching and hoping
that people will come and buy for me so
I hope that helps you're maybe not the
news you wanted to hear but we'll try to
find something you really love about
this business and do that be that person
in your company and get other people
around you who can you know share the
load of the things that you're not good
at or don't know about it you know you
don't have the knowledge and hopefully
that will help you be able to get this
company off the ground and get you to
the point in your life that you're
you're really happy about so I hope that
helps if you guys liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below if you have
some other thoughts for Chris's well I'd
love to see it or if you have your own
question feel free to leave a comment
under the video and we'll see you on the
next episode
you
you